join our american writers series live in
medora north dakota as we explore the
progressive era and the works of
theodore roosevelt
[Music]
this week on booknotes our guest is
roger wilkins history professor at
george mason university he joins us to
discuss his recent book jefferson's
pillow the founding fathers and the
dilemma of black patriotism
[Music]
roger wilkins where did you get the
title jefferson's pillow
the
first memory that jefferson says he ever
had
was of being carried on a pillow
from one of his family's estates to
another by a slave riding on horseback
and
what i tried to do in this book
was to figure out how
i could understand i as a black human
being
could understand
the revolution
considering the fact that it's told
usually as
something that was done by great white
heroes male heroes and nobody else
and um that and the blacks are totally
excluded and the fact that so many of
the founding heroes owned slaves
what i found
in the end was that uh in telling the
story
as it occurred
you had to connect
the blacks
to
the whites because the whites couldn't
have been
who they were
without the blacks
particularly these virginia whites
and they lived life
cushioned by slavery
and so it seemed to me that jefferson's
pillow was a perfect metaphor for what
the way i understood
slavery to have
enriched and lifted and made possible in
the lives of these great founders when
did you decide you wanted to write a
book like this
i think i've been deciding it for years
there's recent research that
indicates that
teenagers brain
do a lot of active formulation ages say
12 to 14.
i was having a conversation with a
friend of mine named kim ken krufsky
right after that period and ken said of
course
i'm convinced that
most of what we do afterwards is
related to what we're doing when we're
12 to 14.
when i was 12 years old i was a
black kid
a lone black kid in all white north end
of grand rapids michigan
and i'd just come from harlem my my
mother had just gotten remarried
after having been a widow for three and
a half years or so
and
i'd lived in harlem
and before that it segregated kansas
city so all of a sudden being in the sea
of white people
the age of 12 in 1944
10 years before
uh brown v board
before the world the world war ii was
over and the country started to shift
around as a result of the war
and in the all-white north end of the
city kids threw stones at me go back
where you came from
yelled [ __ ] at me nobody would talk to
me it's spit on my
bike seat at school
and
soon
that
stopped i made some friends and
things were
pretty good but
the
that was a very traumatic period and
being an adolescent black adolescent
all-white setting is also
extraordinarily difficult
so i think part of me
always has wanted to say
is ask the question is this nation
really mine
can
i
really
have
an emotional ownership with it
comparable to the kind of emotional
ownership that a white kid whose family
just got here say in 1900
um seems to have
and um
that was the genesis also there's a
there's a there's a story that i tell in
the book
uh back in about 1965 when my daughter
amy
who is now quite a distinguished
uh lobbyist for the interest of poor
children here in washington dc
um
was about five or so
her mother and i took her to mount
vernon on a tour
and
in those days there was no mention of
slavery at places like mount vernon and
monticello and gunston hall and so forth
but we ultimately came to a building
called
the quarters
and
amy said well
what are the quarters
and
i said well it's the slave quarters it's
where the slaves lived
and
they followed one of these moments of
chance utter silence
in which this child's piercing voice
broke through and said george washington
old slaves well what's so great about
him then
so
all of these things kind of combine to
propel me toward this book
before we get into a book let me just
ask you the basic questions
about your own life you were born where
kansas city missouri
live next
after my father died when i was eight
we moved from kansas city
to new york to harlem
where we lived for three and a half
years and then my mother
married my stepfather who was a
physician in grand rapids michigan and
she's lived in the same house
since we moved in in 1944 she still
lives there she's 94 years old
and you went to school where well
christmas addicts elementary school and
segregated kansas city
by the way he was
he was one of the heroes he was the
first black
he was the first person killed in the
revolution he was
christmas addicts was a former slave
participated in the boston massacre and
was shot during the boston massacre and
became the first casualty of our
revolution
then i went to
ps46
and
the elementary school in p.s 164 a
junior high school in
harlem
then i moved to grand rapids
finished junior high and high school at
a school called creston high school in
north end of grand rapids
then
the university of michigan for seven
years seven glorious years what'd you
study
uh political science then i went to law
school did you get a phd at michigan no
i got a lot of great michigan
and then what was your first job well
the first lawyer who ever paid me to
do
legal work was thurgood marshall in the
summer between my junior and senior year
in law school
and he offered me a job when i got out
of school but thurgood was the head of
the naacp and he had been kind of an
uncle to me
all my life and then there was my real
uncle who was head of the naacp and also
on the board of the legal defense fund i
figured in between these two giants i'd
never figure out who i was so i went to
a private law firm and did international
law and commercial
litigation for about five years your
uncle being roy wilkins right
your first government job was
i was special assistant to the
administrator of
the agency for international
developments
his name was
fowler hamilton a
missourian who later became a wall
street lawyer and a great friend of
senator stuart simmington
fowler left the government um on
december 7th
1962
and
he was replaced by david bell
who was one of kennedy's brilliant
harvard uh
appointees um
who ran aid until 1966. i left in 64 but
both fowler hamilton and david bell were
wonderful wonderful
mentors to me what was your job at the
justice department
i was
the truth is i was the president's riot
man when i got to the justice department
in well when i started doing this job in
1964
right after the
civil rights act of 64 was signed
there was the first of the urban
eruptions
first wave
new york
both in harlem and in brooklyn and
rochester new york and a number of other
places the next summer was watts
in los angeles
and then
throughout the summers
of the rest of the 60s and
i ran the community relations service
which
[Music]
was supposed to
come in and mediate racial disputes
of the old style like birmingham in the
early 60s but
we had moved past that
and essentially we became the riot
flying squad so i visited i was
at virtually every major eruption in
this country between
65 and
and those
that occurred after dr king was murdered
and you were how old then
well in
64 i was 32 years old
and when i left the government i was
in 69 i was 37 and i always said that
i went to the government when i was 30 i
left where i was i stayed for seven
years and i was 50 years old when i left
well the interesting thing is in your
book you keep talking about the ages of
people like james madison and thomas
jefferson and all they were
not very old i mean that same no that's
right
age range when a lot of us
then after you got
finished with your government service
what'd you do i went to ford foundation
and
directed the foundation's largest
domestic program
it was
the poverty program
and the labor program and the innovative
city program all rolled into one what
years
1969 to 1972. then what
then my journalist
my journalism career my father
was a writer a journalist for a black
paper in kansas city missouri he was roy
wilkins younger brother
and roy also had been a journalist
and had i
had there been any jobs for black people
on newspapers of general circulation in
1953 when i finished college
i would have been in journalism then
but 19 years later i wrote a piece for
the washington post uh
op-ed piece
and
philly shalen and meg greenfield offered
me a job on their editorial page
i thought about it for a little while
and
even though it meant a cut and pay
it was kind of the family business and i
wanted to i kind of wanted to complete
the work that my father who died at 35
hadn't been able to do
so i went uh i worked at the post for
two years on its editorial board and i
went to the and i did a lot of work on
watergate while i was there
the watergate editorials in 72 and many
of them
in 73.
then i went to
the new york times
where i was on the editorial board for
three and a half years or so and then
wrote an urban affairs column until
i left the paper in 1979
and my um
journalism career
ended when i came back here to be
write for the washington star which was
a wonderful afternoon paper
and i thought washington needed two
papers and i asked if i wouldn't come
and try to help it
live
but it only lasted a year and my wife
and i were on a vacation and
in aspen colorado and uh after i'd been
there a year and the editor murray guard
called and woke me up and said roger we
lost the paper i said i didn't leave you
any memo what paper you told no no i'm
saying we lost the paper i said what
paper you top the paper
timing shut us down
so i thought well
just saying something to him i think
this is the end of my this is this ought
to be the end of my
journalism career so i
when did you start teaching at george
mason 1988
what do you teach teach history
both
race law and cultural history i also
teach 20th century political history
media and
presidential politics
i also my love is um
i teach
freshman honors courses
where you're teaching you're just
getting young people to think about
values and think about life from reading
and discussing great books
you teach at george mason you write
about george mason in this book you
include him in the four white virginians
what do you think george mason would
think if he were sitting here today and
just heard your resume
i think he
mason being a
fellow who
looks
through time
would say
that's a good outcome
i would have hoped that
this would have happened to these people
that they could have
gotten free and and taken advantage of
the country as
as
black people have done
why did you include him in the big four
um
because um
i
was looking at the revolution and the
founding
for the things that affect us today
um
both the negative and the positive um
the acquisitiveness
the materialism
uh
the the the freedoms the the structured
governments um
the idealism the racism
um
it seemed to me that mason's insistence
on uh
the inclusion of a set of rights
in the constitution was was was was
central
and
um his um
and his his
leverage on madison in the in the
virginia ratifying convention
um which forced madison to look around
for because madison didn't think these
were needed
uh
solutions and then medicine
taking jefferson's suggestions sent over
from france
that
madison promised
mason and henry and others who were
saying if you don't have this
in if you don't put this in the uh
constitution virginia won't ratify and
that will bring this whole thing down
madison said look okay i promise you
this in the first congress we will
submit a bill of rights okay
and madison henry said okay matt and
their allies said okay
uh it seemed to me that that's that's
central to who we are
um
and um
the other reason was that i was
interested in
deeply interested in washington who
appears to us as a an enigma because
he's
cold granite remote
and one of the things i wanted to do is
to try to figure out who these guys were
before they were
up on the pedestals
and
one of the things that washington well
washington was a this was a it's just a
very interesting person
um he learned how to
be the soldier he was in the fields
as a surveyor and as a young soldier
sleeping under the stars and on
horseback um
he didn't go to college he didn't go to
william and mary or to uh who did
goodwin
uh jefferson and uh and
madison went to the college of new
jersey which is now princeton
and uh
mason was self-taught but he was taught
in his uncle's law library which was
probably the most extensive private law
library in the in virginia at the time
um
washington was not the first and not the
second son these are important things
and he wasn't even
he was the third son and not even by
the first wife but by the second wife so
he was not a favorite child at all and
he was then he looked up to his brother
lawrence who was a friend of the famous
fairfax family
and they had grand balls and cotillions
and that's what young washington aspired
to wealth and to be a dandy and to be a
fancy guy at the balls
and he started getting rich right fast
as fast as he could acquiring lands
and he acquired a wife who made who was
a widow and was the wealthiest widow in
virginia
acquiring more land and
so he was well on his way to just being
kind of a very wealthy fellow who
had no other concerns but
because
the slave over owning gentry was
expected to take its part in governing
helping to govern the colony
he went to the he went to the uh house
of burgesses as of
and he was
but and he he
got there when his older neighbor who
had known him forever was still in the
house
to mentor him so that's one of the
reasons other reasons i view mason
as as
washington's mentor in the arts of
government so that's another reason i
included it george mason's did you say
seven years older than george washington
he was born in 1725 washington in 1732.
and how then were madison and jefferson
as they related to george washington
madison
was the baby he was born in in
1751 and uh uh jefferson in 1743. of
those four men uh
you say a total of 400 slaves among the
four
well
i suppose
if you took
the times when the slave populations at
their places were greatest to be more
because there was a time when washington
had at least 200 slaves and there is a
time when
jefferson is said to have had at least
200 slaves
my sense is that
that
mason
probably never had more than 100 or so
and it's hard to say about madison
because he didn't
he was the only one
who wasn't really a farmer he didn't
run his place
um
you know these other people thought of
themselves as farmers
who went to the government to do these
things but they always wanted to return
to be farmers
um
madison had older relatives who
ran his place and he was what he was
really was a nation builder a man whose
whole career
was uh
was to
build the government so he never
he never ran the plantation and he never
so i never really
monticello i mean uh montpelier
obviously had slaves
but he didn't live there that much and
so
the number of slaves that his family
owned was never in my calculations
come back to all four of these you spent
10 days with nelson mandela in this
country why
well the short answer was that
the
african national congress
wanted
a non-activist host
and they selected for mandela's trip and
they selected harry belafonte
a year this was 1990.
um
i had been very active in the
anti-apartheid movement one of the
leaders of the free south africa
movement
and
harry
knew me
from the civil rights movement
um and he heard me at a meeting one day
when people were discussing the mandela
trip
and there are all kinds of people there
he's got to come to my city you got to
come to my city and they drove me nuts
and i just said look you guys are wrong
this this man is over 70 years old
he's got a job
and his job is not to be our trophy
his job is to raise awareness of the
struggle for south of south africa
freedom to raise the profile of the
african national congress the congress
and to raise money and our job
is to help him do those things and we
would hope to deliver him to the
airplane when he leaves in better health
than he was
when he came here and that means that we
don't wear them out and then we take
good care of them
well
i just thought i was speaking good sense
i left the meeting and i was called back
a couple of hours later said harry's
looking for you desperately and i got
back and here he said i want you to
coordinate the trip and
i
he persuaded me to do it what'd you
learn from him
i learned
from
i learned that
the force of of discipline and character
can be far larger than
eloquence than
the
flashy um
yearning for fame that we see in so many
contemporary politicians
the glibness
this man
this man
was was was received with such love in
this country
i think we'll never see in our lifetimes
anything like it
from boston through the east coast
through the midwest
the west coast it was all the same
it could be epitomized this way coming
in from
john f kennedy airport i looked up
there was a phalanx of policemen who
were supposed to be protecting him and
instead of protecting him by looking
outward they were looking
at him in the car
and some of these big
tough
hard
new york policemen who can be pretty
racist
when let loose some of them
they're almost all crying
mandela every and everybody from
president george h.w bush
to
the lowliest deep person wanted to see
him and touch the hymn
mandela understood this he knew this
but he knew he had a job to do
and he knew that his job was not to come
and
get everybody to shower him with love
and kisses and cheers
he knew that his job was to do what i
said to gather support for
and that's what he got up every morning
and did and he knew
however big the american publicity
machine was making him he knew
that his cause was bigger than he was
so that he maintained his real
discipline inside this huge persona
and he kept his eye
on his cause and used himself
as a tool in service for that cause
and it was mandela and watching mandela
that made me understand washington
i finally said that's exactly what
happened
during
the revolution because the army was the
revolution
without washington there wouldn't have
been any army because it would have
melted away
if he had said well fellas
are you fellow stay here at morristown
or at valley forge i'm going home
just for a week or so
no army
if
he had been less adroit handling the
continental congress which was fractious
and leaders-less in getting resources
and wheedling
no army hence no revolution just
keeping that army together
for those six long years from cambridge
in 1775
to yorktown in 1781
was one of the greatest feats you know
he didn't win many battles
um
but he kept it alive long enough for the
french finally to come and be of
critical assistance
and he won it um
i don't think i would ever have
understood him nearly as well had i not
and there were similar guys in another
sense
although mandela is a lawyer
his real training for leadership came on
robben island
up when he was a prisoner
where he forged this steel
will of his
and
washington's
wasn't the fancy education his education
was as i said in the saddle and under
the stars
and neither man
was
a naturally
gifted orator
but it was
the force of the personality the
discipline
and the will to service
that galvanized each of their societies
so
that's what i learned from it when did
you go back to ghana or go to ghana and
why did you go there
i went to ghana in 1994.
i believe i think i was about 62 years
old
and i went as the chair of the board of
the africa america institute
which is the
oldest and largest american
private american organization that does
human resources development with and for
africans
and we had a conference
in accra
of leaders from africa and the united
states discussing african problems where
is ghana
ghana is on the west coast of
africa
kind of in the gulf of guinea just
under that big bulge
and i had
it's important that i say to you that i
was 62 years old because
it was one of the
moments
in my life
that where i went through a crucible of
identity
in two ways um
the first was that
although i'd been
in africa many times in the past i'd
never been in ghana before
and i saw a lot of people who looked
like me
and i hadn't seen this in other
as a matter of fact in the ghana state
guest house i was looking waiting for
lunch one day and i looked at a painting
on the wall and there was a big funeral
scene
i looked up and to my amazement there
was a person in the scene who looked
just like my father
and i saw a
young woman who looked like my daughter
amy and another
woman who looked like my aunt armeda my
father's sister
so i knew that i was at a place where
some of my relatives had
been shipped out
and i had had these experiences before i
went to the cape coast castle which was
one of those
slave warehouse fort shipping dock
places on the west coast of africa
the gulf of guinea which was one of
those places the big place where
slaves were exported
and i had the experience the just
incredible experience of
first standing in the
in the
rooms where the commandant of the fort
lived
big airy rooms looking out on the ocean
and the places where they had dances and
balls and they
finally went downstairs to where they uh
showed off the merchandise and hosed
them above splashed them off
and then the dungeon
and the dungeon was was the place of of
horror because
there's a little trough in the dungeon
that runs down and that was for urine
and
you could imagine from that
the horrors of being in there sometimes
people were kept there for six weeks or
so before a ship came
occasionally taken out and splashed off
and then sent back down to dark place
you're forced down when you're finally
extruded
through a slim door of no return into
bright sunlight
and i was in this dungeon
imagining
ancestors of mine
and
other people being forced through that
people who had recently been free and
just living their lives
and were caught up for no reason other
than that the slave gathering networks
were
in need of new fodder
and then being
forced
through this door of no return usually
naked so there'd be more hope helpless
into a stinking slave ship and these
places did stink because
they're packed with people and
human waste and everything just and they
could it said that the slaver could be
smelled across you know before it hove
into sight
and so
i was i went through
that door understanding that that that
my some ancestors of mine had gone
through that door and
true that
the question
for me was then
very stark
what is this
idea of being an african in america
which some people say and students of
mine decided
and i realized that as much as i felt
about africa as much
as i
had tried to give to africa in parts of
my life
and as many
african friends as i have
i just i stood there at that door of no
return and
watched the ocean curve
or it curved toward
the americas
that the centuries
from
between the time that my ancestors had
been extruded through that door
and taken across that ocean the
centuries had
turned me into an american i was not an
african in america and my african
friends didn't receive me in africa
president rawlings did not when he gave
me a big hug did not
hug me because i was his african brother
he hugged me because he was a generous
host
he knew i was a person who wanted to
help
and he believed that because i was an
american i had access to american
resources which his country needed so i
was being welcomed as an american not as
an african brother and
i had
vaguely
had
worked that out in my head but never
with both the intellectual and the
emotional power that hit me while i was
in accra at that moment
when you read your book your head snaps
throughout it because you go from this
quote
i feel a rising rage that men so
distinguished and so powerful could have
been so timid about using the power and
the cause of freedom for blacks and
justice for america to where you call
those four virginians great men
well
and and let me just also ask you do you
get
a lot of reaction when you say these
things
in your class yes yeah i do
um
i think one of the advantages of writing
the book
when i did
and as i say in there
i am now writing uh
as i now write i'm a few months older
than washington was when he died
and therefore i'm writing not only with
the weight of injustice and anger and
youthful hope and idealism in me but
the weight of human experience
and the knowledge that
people
don't come in neat
packages and that
all of us
bear as uh as uh
philip roth might say the human stain
and i've lived in washington long enough
to see
very flawed great men
and um so i
and i'm also old enough to
bear the weight on my own soul of my own
flaws
so that
i
could look at these men and see them
shaped by their culture as they were
a culture
which
for them to be who they were required
slaves
a culture which taught them from
childhood
that this was their entitlement that
this is how their life was to be
um just as our culture gives us certain
ideas that we
have to grow up with and sometimes save
us all our lives
so yeah i see them as flawed men
men
who in some parts of themselves knew
that it was wrong to own other human
beings but could not bring themselves to
live
slaveless lives
but who nevertheless
overcame
those shortcomings to do great things
because it seems to me that this country
up to now has uh
has been
a wonder
for human beings including
most of us a number of us who were born
black or native american or
a long-term
hispanic
uh citizens of this country all of us
have suffered uh none more surely than
uh native americans um
but it's really blacks in a in quite a
hideous way but
our
opportunity to participate as citizens
and to change the place
makes it an extraordinary place and it
was
these founders and their colleagues
who left the foundations that made these
things possible at the end of their time
on earth
what did the four each ford do about
their slaves george washington
washington uh in the summer before he
died
revised his will
he had come to the conclusion um
person
lafayette his dearly
beloved sort of son
gave him adoration
but he also pushed him on the issue of
slavery and said this is wrong and you
should do something about it
washington had no children
washington and martha
and but he didn't own all the slaves the
many of the slaves on at mount vernon
were her slaves
and
um
he couldn't do anything about them
they'd come to her in her
when her husband first husband had died
but he wrote a will that freed his
slaves
after his death after her death
and
and he always said near the end of his
life he had early on he had been a just
ordinary pretty tough slave owner at the
end
near the end he wouldn't sell any slaves
anymore um and he surely wouldn't
selling down to places like the west
indies where it was really a bad thing
to do
um
but it made mount vernon
um
unprofitable
too many slaves too many miles to feed
not enough work for them but he wouldn't
sell them because he thought that was
cruel so he really had
come a long way well he he gave he he
uh
ultimately um
made provision in his will as i said and
his wife in her will and freed her
slaves mason
mason
mason made some of those fiery
anti-slavery
i hate slavery it makes tyrants of man
it uh it's detestable but in one speech
it's just detestable but as long as
we're going to have it there should be
protection for that kind of property in
our constitution and he was really
schizophrenic about it but he had a
whole bunch of kids he had
eight or nine children
and he just willed them to his children
the way he did his furniture as horses
um
uh
it was not
some of the things he said were pretty
glorious
um
he didn't want to sign the constitution
because it um
extended the slave trade for 21 years
um
he made the most thunderous anti-slavery
statement at the constitutional
convention
as the
as the
punishments of
of a nation uh can't be uh
can't be
rectified in the hereafter they must be
in this
and they will cause an inevitable chain
of calamities which of course
that's exactly what happened james
madison
uh
madison
i think probably was the one of these
people who was the most enlightened from
the beginning and
clearly enlightened he had a slave
called billy named billy who he took to
philadelphia with him
and billy uh
pennsylvania was a free state and billy
wanted his freedom and
madison freedom and he wrote his father
uh i can't see
denying
billy or any of these people the
liberties that we have just fought to
gain for ourselves
um
he was always a
a milder and a more decent guy but as i
said his
personal life didn't depend on this
interaction with
with slaves but at the end when he was
back in
in
montpelier uh and he was very old um
he he just hated slavery but he dithered
he he
didn't
even that when his young friend edward
cole suggested to him that he'd do
something
he didn't knee at the end he owned and
he tried he thought about it but he
realized that if he got rid of his
slaves it would have left his widow
bankrupt
so he did it away in
the slaves passed on to his wife you
mentioned header calls
what did he do well coles was a
wonderful fellow he was a young the next
generation he was had been a secretary
to both uh
jefferson and madison and he
asked plead with each one of these men
uh in their
elderly years to
free their slaves make a statement do
something to end this what you say will
make a great difference and jefferson in
his usual way yeah it's the next
generation we've done our part
um so it's for you guys so cole said
okay i'm gonna free my slaves don't know
edward don't do that for goodness sakes
because if you feed your slaves in
virginia that's gonna make problems in
virginia so cole said okay
he took all his slaves and he moved to
illinois
and he educated the slaves
to the point where he was sure that they
could be
self-sufficient they freed freedom they
went on to become governor of illinois
every cause of the terrific guy if i
think i remember i think coles county is
where thomas lincoln is buried the same
county
it was named after him
all right finally uh thomas jefferson
what do you do with this place
well jefferson really i i have more
trouble with jefferson than any of these
people
and not
it's not the sally hemings problem
although um
uh it is
it is that jefferson
was a
essentially a devious he was brilliant
no question about that
and he really loved liberty and
but he was he was devious
and he was self-indulgent
here
the country he asked
here's old washington he's done
everything the country has asked him to
do including inventing the presidency so
he wants to go home at the end of the
first term he says i've done everything
please i need to go home
jefferson says wait
jefferson and others
you have to take a second term
you really have to take a second turn
the nation needs you
um you're the unifying force the country
will hang on you so he says okay i'll
stay
a few months later jefferson says i'm
going home i'm resigning as secretary of
state i'm going home i don't need to
risk unlike you i can only need only
consult my own conscience and i want to
go home
and enjoy my home
that was pretty that was really
and at the same time
he is doing politics he's he's now
beginning to be the father of the first
political party and it's the
anti-federalist anti-washington party
and he's encouraging others and
sometimes through others taking shots at
washington and when he goes away he
really takes
shots at the old soldier and the old
soldier was old and he was not doing
terribly well in the presidency at the
end
i'd
and
so that's a kind of self-indulgence and
he also
you know he loved his wine and his
french furniture and his french stuff
and his in his in his
gadgets and all of this stuff and he was
a smart guy and he loved all these
things anything he
loved to find life he had the money to
pay for it
and so he had deep in debt he would sell
slaves in order to pay off his debts but
he just got deeper and deeper in that
so that in the end even if he had had
the inclination
to save his slaves or do something good
with him he couldn't
because he was so indebted so
except for people named hemings
largely
his slaves went
to the winds
what book is this for you
second uh i've edited i've also edited a
book with former senator fred harris but
this is my second book
the first one was a man's life
which was
published when i was about 50
who has
tried to
tell
what it felt like to be raised
as a black person but
in a very
integrated world um
and to try to negotiate that world both
as
an adolescent
and then as a young person in washington
at the time of the civil rights movement
when
opportunities for black people young
black people like me who were well
educated before the movement started
abounded but when resistance to
authority even the authority of the
kennedy and johnson
administrations that is to push them
farther
these were the tensions are you going to
push
for are you going to use
your position of of
power and privilege
to further your own nest and to get
ahead and to be a very successful person
wealthy
or are you going to use it to
um champion the causes of the poorest
people
well i think
i pretty much came down on the side of
trying to champion the cause of the
poorest people
but that is not to say that the siren
songs of seduction uh
that uh corporate america can
give you didn't didn't uh tempt me and
it didn't that they didn't really cause
a very
um searing psychic time for me so all of
that i try to tell in the first book
you talk about the white biographers
yes of all the founding fathers over the
years i want to ask you about history
how much did you trust
what you read are the duma malones and
all the historians about these founding
fathers
we had to read them with a grain of salt
black people were really written out of
of history
and
blacks were there every step of the way
uh you could the country would have been
a far poorer country
at the time of the revolution
had it not been for the blacks had been
smaller
uh
population by 20 percent
um it would have been
a lot less wealthy uh
many much of the
financing of the revolution rested on
the produce of slave labor
then of course slaves were in every
battle from lexington concord on all the
way to yorktown
and as i say none of the these four
founders would have had the time to
think to reason to do politics to
communicate to write their great
treatises without lives that were
cushioned
by slavery in which they had the leisure
to do these things
well
once you start looking at it that way
and you understand the dynamics of their
daily lives and that this was the way it
was and then you go back and read these
other guys well you know that you're
only getting half the story
and
part of the reason i wrote the book
was to correct that
now
then when you get to jefferson and sally
hemmings it is just disgraceful
um i do not know i can't tell you as we
sit here
definitively that jefferson was the
father of sally heming's children
um
the dna evidence suggests that it was
some jefferson some male jefferson fan
alive could have been his brother could
have been his uncle
most likely person was thomas jefferson
himself because even dumas malone
who wouldn't continue this this
countless this idea
did note that
jefferson was present
around sally hemmings nine months before
she gave birth to each
of the children so the dna evidence plus
that
plus the uh evidence of
testimony from madison hemings uh one of
sally's children that his mother told
him that jefferson was their father
makes a pretty
strong case well these
historians just
wouldn't
they just
couldn't believe it they wouldn't
do it so they took this
silly story that it was
the one of jefferson's nephews samuel or
peter carr
well that's just not incredible
if you put it together with the fact
that jefferson was around
nine months before each of these kids
was born because you'd say well these
fellows
only went to see sally when uncle was
there
i mean what does that didn't make any
sense
around the time we're taping this
there's a controversy about a jefferson
historian joseph ellis who wrote the
pulitzer prize winning american sphinx
and i want to ask you because you're a
student of all this
what impact
does that have where he was shown to be
telling his students that he had fought
in the vietnam war and a lot of other
things that he hadn't done what was your
take when you saw that does that
do any damage to historians
no
it does i
admired american sphinx very much and i
um
read it uh with great admiration as i
was uh working on this book
and um
i have i and i have uh founding brothers
at home and and
and i fully intend to read it and i also
want to go back and read
adam's book before i read mccullough's
book because i think
probably he is ellis is probably the
best adams biographer there is although
i certainly like david very much but
i think that i think the ellis
business is not about history it's about
joe ellis
i think it's a i think it's a horrible
tragedy
because here is a man of
uh great intellectual
uh and artistic gifts and he puts them
together in his scholarship and in his
writing is just just wonderful
and he has
ascended the peak of his profession
he is
his just his writing just leave alone as
teaching
my editor on this book was one of the
students
and i haven't talked to her about it
about this but
she reveres him as a teacher
but his writing has enriched everybody
who cares about
understanding our country started so
this
strange driving personal need of his to
get something more from the world
than he's earned
it's just a terrible personal tragedy
and it did it
it makes me
unspeakably sad and i don't even have
never met him i've just admired his work
so how do you know when to trust a
historian
um you read and you
you weigh and you you look at other
materials
you
and usually it's not a question
of trust i don't i don't
believe people sit down to write
lying books
but we all see the world through our own
lens we've only
got we don't
nobody's toddlerassa you know
we all had parents we're all born
someplace
somebody
spitting our cake one day you know all
of this we bring to the table
and
we're all interpreters
uh we're all
filling in
blanks
you've got this fact and this fact this
fact and this fact in this fact so what
do you make of it so you it's not so
much trusting it's sifting and
evaluating and it's it's
um
evaluating inferences
that people have made
and uh of
trying to
understand whether they have made
a very hard effort to
give you everything you need to draw
your own inferences and they're not just
forcing you to drink this water right
here
what then how much do you trust the
story that thomas jefferson had that he
really first memory was really riding
around on a
was back of a horse on the pillow
no he was the the the slave was holding
the pillow do i believe it
do i believe he remembered that
how old do you think he would have been
well that's the other problem you know
um
you you would think that he would have
been pretty small to be on a pillow
um
and
so and he was given to
exaggeration and hyperbole you know
the tree of liberty
needs to be nourished by blood every
generation or so i mean it's you know
the guy said some wild things so
do i believe it no do i have to believe
it in order to
use his words as my metaphor no
he said it
he gave it to us as
part of
because it is part of him whether it was
true or not
there is something that made him
decide
to
tell us that this was his earliest
memory
now that's real
that decision that thomas jefferson made
that's real
and
it seems to me that that the metaphor is
therefore
not only
authentic but
in my judgment pretty powerful and
david mccall's book on john adams the
only thing he could find that john adams
had done when it came to slavery that i
don't know what how he defined it but he
defended
as a lawyer
people who owned slaves
other than that no slaves seemed to
deplore it his wife deplored it what was
it about that family that didn't
have an interest in slaves and all these
virginians that did
well i there were
some virginians who didn't own slaves i
mean they were playing for james in
those places because they were poor
they're too poor to actually
uh there were a few other virginians who
didn't there was one virginian
who used
about 1787 used
mason's words in the introduction to
the virginia declaration of rights
saying i believe that all men
are by nature free and equal and
therefore
i don't believe in slavery and i am
hereby manufacturing my slave he gave up
i don't know fifth 12 16 slaves
um
but massachusetts society and i don't
say that i'm not denigrating adam's
character at all adams was an
enormous human being
with great integrity
but massachusetts
did not depend
for its economy on
uh an industry that needed slaves
virginia
existed on tobacco that was its economy
and you couldn't
you well
they figured out in back in the 17th
century that you couldn't do
tobacco without slaves now
that may have been a wrong judgment
maybe they could have done tobacco
without slaves
but that's not
the culture that these men inherited
that was in place
they were born in it to and as babies
they learned it whereas
atoms they were just farmers who farmed
their own small farms and they were
farms
that families could farm themselves they
were far more in that sense
self-sufficient and
i guess that's why
yankees were plenty and virginians were
cavaliers
here's the book jefferson pillow our
author has been roger wilkins thank you
very much thanks brian
[Music]
[Music]
for a transcript of this book notes call
1-800-777-text
for video copy call 1877 on c-span to
learn more about book notes visit us on
the world wide web at booknotes.org next
week on booknotes our guest is walter
burns author of making patriots book
notes can be seen every sunday on c-span
at 8pm eastern and 8pm pacific time
[Music]
you